guten abend und willkommen zu unserer
corona sprechstunde freut mich dass ihr
dabei seid fußball vormenschen leeren
rängen so könnte die bundesliga bald
eventuell aussehen wenn sie wieder
startet so könnte sich die dfl das
zumindest vorstellen heute hat sie ihr
konzept vorgestellt mit dem sie die
politik davon überzeugen möchte dass es
ebenso einen neustart der saison geben
soll
geht also bei der fußball wieder los
darüber wollen wir hier heute sprechen
und wir wollen uns mal ganz genau
anschauen was die dfl da eigentlich ganz
genau plant und wie sinnvoll das ist
wenn ihr fragen zum thema habt dann
stellt sie gerne hier unten in die
kommentare und miriam kasse zeigt uns
jetzt erstmal was die der felder so
geplant hat wenn dfl und politik sich
einigen könnte es in gut zwei wochen
wieder losgehen mit der bundesliga sie
ist spielbereit und das jederzeit wenn
der tag ist da sein wird dann werden wir
bereit sein und falls die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung entscheiden dass dieser
tag der neunte mai wäre dann werden wir
am 9 mai bereit
worauf man sich einstellen müsste sind
geisterspiele vielleicht bis ins
kommende jahr
leere stadien stille ränge
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber alternativlos
spiele ohne zuschauer ist nicht das was
wir wollen
aber es ist für den moment das einzige
was machbar scheint streng definiert
also die anzahl der personen in den
stadien
außerdem gebe es klare hygiene regeln
für die spieler kein team foto etwa und
kein handshake sowie umfangreiche von
der liga finanzierte corona tests
mindestens einmal pro woche und auf
jeden fall direkt am tag vor einem spiel
das wären bis saisonende mehr als 20.000
tests unter vorbehalt
das ist bewusst dass für den fall den
sich wirklich niemand wünscht dass
nämlich zum beispiel sich die lage
wieder verschlechtert und test
kapazitäten tatsächlich zum engpass
würden
der profifußball selbstverständlich
zurückstehen muss und selbstverständlich
zurückstehen wird sollte bald wieder
gespielt werden wären alle
bundesligisten dabei akut drohende
insolvenzen wie für schalke 04 sind
vorerst abgewendet nach einigung der dfl
mit fast allen medien partnern erhalten
die vereine tv gelder in höhe von etwa
300 millionen euro
doch auch hier gibt es ein aber ich weiß
aber auch sollte die saison nicht wieder
starten oder abgebrochen werden müssen
greifen gewisse mechanismen zur
rückführung von zahlungen diese könnten
dann erneut zu wirtschaftlichen
engpässen führen
gegebenenfalls zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt die dfl hat die vorlage
gegeben der ball liegt jetzt bei der
politik die bundeskanzlerin wird in der
kommenden woche mit den länderchefs über
eine mögliche sonderrolle des fußballs
entscheiden also den baldigen
wiedereinstieg in den spielbetrieb und
per skype zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt zdf
sport reporter thomas wark mit dem wir
das alles ein bisschen einordnen wollen
guten abend thomas thumann hatte ich das
eigentlich überrascht was die dfl der
heute vorgelegt hat
nach allem was mir am montag erlebt
haben als die bild -zeitung der schon so
ein leicht populistischen gipfel der
veranstaltet hat mit herrn seifert von
der dfl mit allen club bossen und so
weiter und so fort
da kam das nicht mehr überraschen das
ganze klingt so ein bisschen wie ein
abgekartetes spiel überrascht aber nicht
denn einigen fußball-vereinen steht das
wasser der ist zum also dass da
unbedingt etwas passieren muss und der
einzige weg der aus dem stand heraus
führen kann aus dem wasser heraus führen
kann
der bundesliga jetzt gibt es ja durchaus
schon reaktionen und kritik auch hier
bei uns in den kommentaren hier schreibt
zum beispiel murray bei youtube so sehr
ich auch den fußball vermisse das signal
gerade an kinder und jugendliche wäre
völlig falsch und das haben wir ja auch
schon aus der politik gehört und das ist
ja auch genau der punkt die politik
entscheidet ja am ende ob das überhaupt
so kommt oder nicht gibt es da jetzt
schon weitere reaktion
nicht unbedingt die leute sind alle ein
bisschen vorsichtig für waren gerade die
politiker also wer angela merkel heute
gesehen hat der konnte feststellen wie
sie von vorsicht getrieben war und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie so
einfach sagt jawoll jungs am 9
wird wieder gespielt wie wird sich diese
entscheidung schwerer machen
die frage ist was machen ihre vor
ausbrechenden ministerpräsidenten in nrw
und bayern
denn die wird dann ihre chance sich
weiter zu profilieren die wenn das
rädchen ein bisschen weiter vorantreiben
es ist ein zweischneidiges schwert auf
der einen seite die berechtigten sorgen
viele eltern wir können unsere kinder
nicht in die kita schicken auf die
spielplätze schon gar nicht und die
herren millionäre gegen den
fußballspielen gehen ihren beruf nach
da passt irgend etwas nicht zusammen auf
der anderen seite muss man aber auch
sagen das sicherheitspaket dass die dfl
leute vorgestellt hat dass wir schon
kannten vorher das eben nur 300 maximal
300 leute in die stadien gehen können
das ist schon sehr professionell
vorbereitet also ich glaube da muss man
nicht allzu viele fürchten es gibt ja
auch noch einen kritikpunkt der fast
immer genannt wird und zwar sind dass
die tests die stattfinden sollen jede
woche da kamen einige kommentare bei uns
dazu da kommen hier noch rein und zwar
zum beispiel von philipp bei youtube der
schreib 20.000 test sie sind das an der
pflege bei der feuerwehren der polizei
oder in anderen systemrelevanten berufen
angebracht oder sascha schreibt das ist
eine schande dass knappe corona tests
für so eine nichtigkeit verschwendet
werden und es gab ja sogar auch vom rk
ii dazu und kommentar der auch eher
kritisch war hat er die dfl der heute in
irgendeiner form darauf reagiert auf
diese kritik
sie haben noch mal betont das ist bei
etwa 20.000 tests aufnehmen gesamtanteil
von 0,4 prozent kommt das ist ein
absolut überschaubar das ganze hat aber
mehr sonne ethisch-moralische variante
auf der einen seite
diese tests das ist nicht sonderlich
viel 20.000 in gesamter und aber es gibt
immer noch viele menschen die wissen gar
nicht wie sie an test frank kommen
können ich kenne persönlich leute diesen
risikopatienten die haben zwei wochen
auf den test warten müssen und die
verstehen natürlich jetzt die welt nicht
mehr
wieso sie so lange warten mussten und
die fußballer mir nix dir nix wieder
anfangen können das passt nicht zusammen
irgendwie er im prinzip schon mittendrin
bei den spielern auf dem platz die
sollen getestet werden was würde denn
passieren wenn jetzt ein spieler positiv
getestet wird muss dann eventuell die
ganze mannschaft in quarantäne und die
gegner mannschaft dann natürlich auch
und dann haben wir ja bald schon wieder
keine saison oder genauso ist es das ist
doch genau der punkt der die sache
prekär und interessant macht was ist
wenn einer positiv getestet worden ist
muss er in quarantäne muss der rest der
mannschaften quarantäne müssen nicht
alle ohnehin in quarantäne so lange bis
die liebe zu ende gespielt ist damit sie
mit ihren familienangehörigen nicht in
berührung kommen was ist denn wenn der
spieler beginnt hat das in der kita ist
der andere geht in die schule und die
infiziert sich um bekommen nach hause
also dieses wäldchen muss noch ein
bisschen durchdacht werden
das ist der einzige schwachpunkt in
diesem strategiepapier der dfl
jetzt sollen ja ganz bewusst in den
stadien keine fans seien einfach um zu
schützen
hier kommen wir ganz klar schon
kommentare zum beispiel peter schreibt
bei facebook dass er glaubt so lange
live übertragen wird werden sich dann
werden sich viele fans untereinander in
ihren wohnungen zum bier treffen um sich
gemeinsam die spiele anzusehen und wir
haben es ja auch schon zum beispiel bei
den geisterspielen die schon
stattgefunden haben auch gesehen dass
ich fänds vor den stadien gesammelt
haben es da nicht eine gefahr die große
gefahr ist erst mal gebannt so lange die
gastronomie nicht auf macht denn das war
so der hauptpunkt wurde sich alle
getroffen haben beim bier am tresen dann
live geguckt gut das feld nun schon mal
flach es sei denn die gastronomie öffnet
kurzfristig wieder das andere problem
ist privater natur da haben wir alle
keinen einfluss darauf in die politik
schon gar nicht denn wer will schon
durch die wohnblocks gehen und
observieren blockwarte haben wir so
schön wenn du in diesem land also das
ist so ein bisschen ein knackpunkt wie
kriegen wir das in den griff ich glaube
die polizei wird in der lage sein
ansammlungen rund um die stadien zu
verhindern aber was an die privatwohnung
passiert dann haben sie keinen zugriff
darauf
thomas jährigen gleich noch weiter wir
sind schon bei den fans und wollen bei
denen jetzt auch erstmal bleiben und uns
mal anschauen wie die diese pläne
eigentlich finden und das zeigt andreas
eck
es gibt die fans die sich nach der
bundesliga sehnen nach ablenkung in
schweren zeiten
aber es gibt viel kritik im netz an
plänen die saison bald fortzusetzen
die einen befürchten dass der stadt
kontaktverbot treffen zum gemeinsamen
fernsehen oder vorstadien geben könnte
andere werfen der dfl vor es gehe ihr
nur um den profit es gibt aber auch
verständnis und lob für den dfl chef
seifert und seinen auftritt der das
beste für sein unternehmen versucht die
fußballer selbst halten sich auf ihren
sozialen kanälen auffällig bei diesem
thema zurück aber natürlich wird es in
städtischen grafiken aufgearbeitet die
vorbildfunktion des fußballs wird im
netz thematisiert
die meiste kritik ernten aber die
geplanten tests wie die beteiligten der
geisterspiele und wir schauen hier mal
in die kommentare wie ihr so zum thema
steht hier schreibt zum beispiel helga
auf facebook relativ kritisch solange
die kinder nicht auf die spielplätze
dürfen sollte die bundesliga sich
zurückhaltend
ganz ähnlich äußert sich eva die sagt
auch die so lange spielplätze dicht sind
sollte das auch bei der bundesliga so
seien hier geht es wohl nur ums geld
schreibt sie noch dazu
außerdem hat sagen angst um die
gesundheit nicht nur um das der spieler
sondern er schreibt auch sind ja nicht
nur die spieler bei den geisterspielen
anwesend sondern auch die menschen
hinter den kulissen und hinter den
tribünen
da geht es in die richtung aber wir
haben ja auch ein kommentar auf youtube
der ist positiv lasst sie doch spielen
wo ist das problem
es muss doch weitergehen oder was ist
der plan dann gibt es wenigstens etwas
ablenkung und wir haben außerdem eine
kleine umfrage gemacht wir schalten mal
kurz auf meinen moderation slept ob bei
facebook und haben euch gefragt wie ihr
das seht und dabei ist rausgekommen 28
prozent sagen auf jeden fall bundesliga
stattfinden sie gut und überwältigende
72 prozent in dieser nicht
repräsentativen umfrage muss man
natürlich sagen sagen nein saison
abbrechen sollte nicht weitergehen
thomas das würde ich direkt mal gerne an
uns weitergeben weil das ist ja
eigentlich schon im prinzip erstaunlich
also jetzt unsere kleine umfrage ist
natürlich sehr extrem mit 72 prozent
dagegen
aber das ist ja so ein bisschen sogar
der tenor unter den den vereinen die
sagen wir wollen nicht unbedingt ein
staat oder interessant ist ich habe
heute nachmittag für eine dokumentation
die am sonntag in der woche sport
reportage senden auf seinem
facebook-account auch so eine umfrage
gestartet inzwischen haben knapp 100
leute geantwortet und der tenor ist
versteckens gleich mit dem was mir
gerade erzählt daß nämlich dass etwa 70
prozent sagen nicht wieder laufen lassen
die liga abbrechen
irgendeinen zum meister küren und keine
absteiger es ist wohl schon eine große
sorge der menschen die auch so einen
emotionalen des
zwischen sich und den fußball gebracht
haben wir ganz interessante entwicklung
die wir ja gerade beobachten können
sascha fragt er auf you tube wieso
bekommt der fußball sonderrecht oder
wieso sollte er sonderrechte bekommen
wohl besser gesagt und andere sportarten
oder vereine zum beispiel nicht wissen
das eigentlich bei anderen sportarten
gibt es auch irgendwelche überlegungen
es gab überlegungen am ende war die
wirtschaftskraft dieser sportarten nicht
hoch genug fußball ist ein hoch
kompliziertes gebilde die dfl deutsche
fußball liga generiert jedes jahr 1,4
milliarden euro und wenn die sagen da
sind arbeitsplätze in gefahr da müssen
ganze vereine zu machen dann ist das ein
totschlagsargument und das schlägt alle
anderen sportarten
du sprichst schon an nämlich die
arbeitsplätze da gehen auch einige von
unseren usern hier drauf ein und zwar
zum beispiel jörg der sagt er ist dafür
dass die saison wieder anfängt da hängt
für einige vereine die existenz dran und
ganz ähnlich ist claudius von facebook
da schreibt sie wer es noch nicht
mitbekommen hat ohne wenigstens die tv
gelder gehen die vereine pleite wie
dramatisch ist dann die finanzsituation
grad bei den vereinen
in zahlen ausgedrückt bedeutet das dass
13 von insgesamt 36 profi-vereinen stark
gefährdet sind
bei einem ist es prekär und das ist der
ruhmreiche traditionsreiche fc schalke
die haben 200 millionen euro schulden
die haben ne menge angestellte die haben
noch mal 100 millionen in ihr
vereinsgelände investiert den steht das
wasser die ganze zeit schon mehr als
über den hals das sind sehr prekäre
situation aber auch das ist so eine
zweischneidige sache
die haben schon vor der saison nicht
ganz sauber gespielt und sind mit diesen
hohen schulden in dieser saison
reingegangen wäre angeschlagen
diese krise ist kann ich erwarten dass
er gesund aus der krise raus kommt also
das ist kein wunder das system jetzt so
schlecht geht und das ist so ein
bisschen auch das gute bei dieser krise
spielt so ein bisschen wahrheit nach
oben du siehst jetzt langsam wie
gewirtschaftet wird und dass nicht alles
immer so seriös ist wie wir das manchmal
darstellen
oder wie es dargestellt wird da passt
ganz gut ein kommentar von jeanette bei
facebook dazu die schreibt komisch viele
vereine zahlen für spielergehälter
jenseits von gut und böse kaufen spieler
für unsummen
und jammern dann dass die existenz
gefährdet ist also du sagst da ist
einfach schon von vornherein einfach ein
bisschen was falsch gelaufen müssen die
vereine da grundsätzlich was überdenken
natürlich muss sie das was mich wundert
also es gibt natürlich sprechen nicht
für alle fans gibt es gibt möglichkeiten
es gibt dort und es gibt bayern münchen
das sind für alle die hoch seriös
arbeiten und die auch wirtschaftlich gut
aufgebaut sind die auch antizyklisch
gedacht haben die in guten zeiten ein
bisschen was auf die seite geschafft
haben für für die zeiten wo es eben
nicht so gut läuft aber das gros der
anderen vereine stopft ein loch nach dem
anderen verteilt vom konto auf konto und
wundert sich am ende das widder nix
übrig geblieben ist
das ist so ein bisschen das große
problem und daran müssen die arbeit bei
1,4 generierten milliarden der dfl
wundere ich mich dass da kein not konto
zur verfügung steht das dann für vereine
wie schalke 04 da ist und jetzt müssen
sie alle warten dass die 300 millionen
euro die letzte fernsehtag schein geht
damit sie wieder anja weiter überleben
können das ist alles auf kante genäht
und bisschen kurzfristig gedacht
das heißt also wären die finanziellen
probleme gelöst wenn jetzt die
geisterspiele stattfinden dürften
fürs erste diese branche wird auf jeden
fall bezahlt bis auf einen
rechteverwerter ich weiß nicht genau wie
es ist bis auf einen haben sie alle
bezahlt das heißt es sind jetzt etwa 300
millionen euro an die vereine geflossen
der haken bei der sache ist sollten sich
jetzt eine oder mehrere spieler
infizieren da müsste dieses geld
zurückgezahlt werden und dann wäre das
problem nur vertrag der untergang
mancher vereine nur aufgehoben also das
ist alles sehr kompliziert und
finanztechnisch auch nicht sehr seriös
und noch muss man ja sagen hat die
politik einfach nicht entschieden am 30
april soll es unter anderem darum gehen
wenn dort jetzt entschieden wird bis
ende des jahres keine bundesliga was
bedeutet das denn für die vereine und
was glaubst du was dann in gang kommt
bei der dfl
dann wird es erstmal darauf ankommen was
machen die anderen ligen in europa wenn
natürlich in italien in frankreich in
spanien weiter gespielt wird dann werden
deutsche profis versuchen in diesen
ligen zu kommen um dort geld zu
verdienen
ich glaube es gibt für dieses szenario
noch keinen notplan auch das ist keine
sonderlich positive angelegenheit die
bundesliga wird zu einem teil den bach
runtergehen
vielleicht kann man sich aber auch so
darauf einigen das ist keine strafzölle
gibt das ist die die einrichtung die man
immer sagen angewendet haben eine
unsauber gewirtschaftet hat dann sind
punkte abgezogen worden
dann gab es einen zwangsabstieg ins
amateurlager oder eine liga darunter in
die zweite liga vielleicht kann man
dieses strafmaß diesen strafenkatalog in
diesem jahr einfach mal aussetzen
aufgrund der besonders prekären
situation und dann überlegen wie retten
wir uns ins nächste jahr über es kann
durchaus sein dass frau merkel
entscheidet das bis ende des jahres
nicht mehr gespielt wird aber auch dafür
muss das professionelle pläne geben dann
fängst du eben mit dem nächsten
kalenderjahr die nächsten saison an und
spielt das pokalfinale dass 2020
stattfinden sollte da spielst du dann
eben im märz 2021 kollidieren könnte das
mit den terminplänen von olympia und der
europameisterschaft der
fußball-europameisterschaft aber das
sind noch ungelegte eier
heute war aber schon von einer gewissen
rettungsaktionen zumindest zu lesen
die von den clubs beschlossen worden ist
wie sieht die genau aus es gibt
verschiedene rettungsaktionen die eine
maßnahme die schon ziemlich früh
gegriffen etwa gehaltsverzicht viele
profis verzichten auf 20 prozent ihres
gehaltes
das ist in toto eine kleine überlebens
maßnahme wird aber einen verein wie
schalke 04 nicht am leben erhalten
können es gibt andere aktionen lassen
sie beantragt frankfurt reden die haben
erkannt dass die soziale not in ihrem
umfeld so großes in frankfurt dass sie
sich entschlossen haben t shirts zu
verkaufen auf jetzt steht da drauf das
ist und auf ross mutter und die haben in
der ersten woche ich glaube über 30.000
davon verkauft stückpreis 20 euro also
600.000 euro die an fünf karitative
frankfurter einrichtung geflossen sind
das ist beispiele für die liga und zeigt
das ist noch mehr geht
als gehaltsverzicht und verschachtelte
spielchen also das war eine ziemlich
jährige aktion und absolut
nachahmenswert
trotzdem würde ich ganz gerne noch mal
auf diese gehaltsfrage kommen weil
dadurch aus hier auch user kommentare
kam man muss ja schon sagen also viele
müssen jetzt gerade in kurzarbeit die
nicht arbeiten gehen können die
fußballer können ja im prinzip auch
nicht arbeiten gerade da schreibt philip
zum beispiel die fußball millionäre
sollen ihre gehälter an das personal der
fussballclubs spenden wird das wirklich
ernsthaft überlegt haben das schon
spieler gemacht oder sind das vor allem
forderungen
ich kenne keinen spieler der sein gehalt
komplett und eine karitative einrichtung
weiter geben würde wenn wir über
spitzengehälter reden dann sprechen wir
über etwa eine million im jahr
die zu verdienen ist das allerdings gibt
es nur bei vereinen in münchen und in
dortmund das sind eben die die die
großvereine dieser liga das ist aber
nicht repräsentativ für das ganze
spieler umfällt da gibt es leute die
verdienen weitaus weniger und da kann
ich schon nach verstehen die sagen unser
gehalt das lassen wir mal schön bei uns
aber es gibt auch trainer wie in berlin
bruno labbadia der hatten neuen job
angetreten hat gesagt ich will erst
gehalt haben wenn diese krise
ausgestanden ist und wenn wir richtig
arbeiten können
auch das ist ein gutes beispiel in jedem
verein wird das ein bisschen anders
gehandelt aber fest steht fast alle
vereine konnten sich darauf einigen
mindestens 20 prozent der gehälter
einzusparen hier ist ein kommentator
martin will ich mir ganz gerne nochmal
mit dem gucken und zwar schreibt die
admiral auf twitter warum soll die
heilige kuh fußball eine extrawurst
erhalten das haben wir jetzt heute schon
in relativ vielen kommentaren gelesen
und schreibt weiter nur für ein multi
millionen geschäft das keinen sozialen
nutzen hat und da will ich mal ein
richtiges fragezeichen hinter setzen
weil im prinzip muss man ja schon sagen
fußball ist doch trotzdem auch inhalt
von ganz vielen menschen und bestimmt
die wochenenden und es ist wichtig dass
würdest du hier zustimmen dass das
keinen sozialen nutzen hat oder könnte
das nicht doch eine ablenkung in der
korona zeit sein
ich kann mir schon vorstellen und ich
zähle mich ja dazu dass er schon eine
ablenkung sein würde
am samstag wieder gekickt wird wobei ich
einräumen muss ein spiel ohne zuschauer
ist eine grausame angelegenheit dass es
ich will jetzt keine großen vergleiche
bringen
es ist fürchterlich es macht keinen spaß
es fehlt dir 80 prozent dessen was wir
gewohnt bis dort zu erleben
die andere sache ist der soziale nutzen
vom fußball
es ist mal angefangen als eine
unterhaltungsbranche ganz ehrlich ganz
naiv und mit schönen vielen beispielen
das ist aber nicht lange geblieben die
sache ist heute so kommerzialisiert ich
sag jetzt auch mal turbo
kommerzialisiert und manchmal kommt es
mir so vor als sei diese ganze krise
eingetreten an einem zeitpunkt dieser
saison
da die blase sowieso kurz davor war zu
platzen es ist eine blase machen wir uns
nichts vor es gibt eine entkopplung des
leistungs fußballs vor dem rest der
gesellschaft darüber haben wir schon
viel philosophiert in diesen tagen kommt
das alte thema wieder hoch also fußball
ist eine insel in unserer gesellschaft
die wir nicht überbewerten sollten aber
die von turbokapitalistischen merkmalen
geprägt ist jetzt reden wir die ganze
zeit hier über deutschland aber das ist
eine pandemie die weltweit ist lass uns
doch mal ganz kurz gucken was da zum
beispiel bei europa league oder
champions league los es haben die auch
solcher konzepte wie die dfl zum
beispiel im vollen wieder loslegen die
uefa die er verantwortlich ist für die
champions league und für die europa
league die warte da was aus unseren
liegen wird sie hat die dringende
empfehlung gegeben alle ligen zu ende zu
spielen damit man
qualifikationskriterien für die nächste
saison hat aber die nächste saison das
ist schnee von von von übermorgen
da liegt noch ein bisschen was an denn
die jetzigen runden müssen ja auch noch
zusammen gespielt werden aber da gibt
sich die uefa noch bedeckt und hat aber
schon zu erkennen gegeben nötigenfalls
rechnen ihr seid einfach thomas ganz
herzlichen dank wir müssen noch abwarten
das bleibt irgendwie im prinzip unser
fazit am 30 april wissen wir vielleicht
mehr und vielleicht sprechen wir dann
wieder und ganz herzlichen dank auch an
euch fürs zu sehen für die vielen
kommentare und fragen die hier gekommen
sind nächste woche ist daher brockerhoff
hier wieder für euch da ich wünsche euch
einen schönen abend
[Musik]
und wenn euch diese corona sprechstunde
gefallen hat dann gefällt euch
vielleicht auch diese hier
da haben wir mit einem faktencheck über
falsch informationen rund um corona
gesprochen oder ihr klickt hier da könnt
ihr euch einfach alle unsere
sprechstunden anschauen oder ihr lasst
uns hier ein abo da das wird uns sehr
freuen